this street corner is a versus turf for
the past three years he's been coming
here every day with his shoeshine kit to
wait for customers he earns around a
euro for each pair of shoes Abbas is
just 14 but isn't attending school he
has to help support his family guitar
the shrimp do rather she is gifted two
of my brothers died in the Civil War
then my family fled Syria our rent is
about two hundred and fifty euros how
would we pay that if I went to school
what are you Abbas is one of tens of
thousands of Syrian refugee children in
Istanbul who spend their days on the
streets many are alone here after
becoming separated from their parents
during their flight the children are
easy prey for criminals and increasingly
for radical Islamists as well in this
video human rights activists filmed
Arabic speaking men trying to take
Syrian orphans away allegedly to a Quran
school but it's more likely that they
were trying to recruit the boys to fight
for Islamic state witnesses intervened
and called the police just in time in
Istanbul police recently investigated a
Quran school for Syrian and Turkish
children a branch of is was said to be
operating out of the same building
several arrests were made but the Quran
classes are still being held
cherry quartz angelini been girl ooh I
saw the police raid where they arrested
a supposed member of is but I'm sure
that has nothing to do with the Koran
school they're good people but in this
neighborhood parents are alarmed even
the most religiously conservative are
afraid of is growl cosa di chua litter
quran class first they give the children
regular religious instruction and then
they brainwash them we don't send our
children there anymore like you say hola
mucho good Shazza barakat says
independent schools are the only way to
keep children out of Quran classes run
by is and their sympathizers just one in
three Syrian refugee children in Turkey
attends an independent school berikut
was an educator in Syria and runs one of
the few schools for refugees in Istanbul
the Turkish authorities have tolerated
her school but provided little by way of
active support berikut now hopes to
receive some of the promised financial
aid from the EU without access to
education refugee children are
vulnerable to radicalization as Barack
out knows well in my son Omar went back
to Syria to fight because he couldn't go
to school here in Istanbul he joined the
rebels and was killed bubblin of the
head he was just 16 years old two weeks
later I opened this school but
unfortunately it was too late for my son
without schooling many refugee children
will develop a hatred of the west and
start getting bad ideas joining the ious
terror group is out of the question for
a bus and his friends but he says he's
also been approached by men who were
recruiting for Islamic state
yeah one of the de l'Arc it up sunday
together this on a syrian man came to me
he asked me if I'd crossed the border
with him to fight my mother didn't send
another night honorable life he told me
he had lots of money but I told him I
don't want to fight Oh them beat us rely
you did then I pointed him out to a
policeman care of Jenna they arrested
him
is is likely to keep sending recruiters
here to try their luck for them the
young Syrian refugees on the streets of
Istanbul are easy prey
you